und sie schicken ihre werke mit davon
gekommen
sie
ruft
[Musik]
ein gästehaus auf der insel bali
patricia und romano zu die wollen aus
dem alltag ausbrechen
familie folglich sie sucht ihr glück in
kanada in den rocky mountains bauen sie
ein holzfäller unternehmen auf
tobias bayer und michael paris wollen
endlich etwas eigenes eine kleine bar
auf weite ventura
[Musik]
in kanada brauchen familie volk und ihr
mitarbeiter mirko eine pause auf dem weg
zu ihrem neuen zuhause
ich hätte dich aber du bist eine
schnecke
die kräfte lassen langsam nach seit mehr
als einem monat leben folgt nur noch aus
dem koffer vor vier tagen sind sie in
kanada angekommen und immer noch fehlen
200 kilometer bis zum ziel da kommt eine
schweizer bäckerei gerade recht
so hole
und schon marx langsam nicht mehr
[Gelächter]
erst sieht
nur noch drei stunden dann müssten sie
im dorf clearwater sein und ihr neues
haus übernehmen
[Musik]
los
in der letzten folge reisten die
holzernte maschinen bereits voraus
nach langem hin und her mit ihrem visum
konnte sich die familie endlich nach
kanada verabschieden das senkt der meter
auf bali begann romano alleine mit der
renovation des gästehauses und hatte
mehr arbeit als gedacht ehefrau patricia
räumte in der schweiz ihren arbeitsplatz
die vorfreude auf bali war getrübt
auf fuerteventura machten sich tobias
und michael an den ausbau ihres lokals
aber eine wohnung die eigen passt
konnten sie nicht finden
[Musik]
in kanada sind volks wieder andere ohne
pause christian hätte für einen tisch in
der swissbau corian gestanden doch
ehefrau simone wollte weiter
in meiner sicht einen super oft haben
die leute halten uns schneller strässer
der traum vom auswandern hat simone viel
abfall sie hat sich um die visa
gekümmert das haus der familie in der
schweiz geräumt und das büro ihres
forstbetriebes ordentlich an die neuen
besitzer übergeben
[Musik]
sechs tore und es kommen muss und ich
einfach mein vater erklärt sie
das neue zuhause immer noch fast 200
kilometer entfernt
[Musik]
auch werte ventura suchen tobias bayer
und lebensgefährte michael paris
dringend nach einer wohnung sie wollen
geld sparen und so schnell wie möglich
raus aus ihrem teuren ferienappartement
hoffnungsfroh besuchen sie die größte
immobilienagentur der insel
wir haben erfahren dass wir eine wohnung
anschauen können sicher ich hole die
schlüssel und dann können wir gleich los
die wohnung liegt in einer großen
überbau die anlage ist riesig
wunderschöne tropische gärten haben wir
hier
ein weiterer vorteil die wohnung liegt
in der nähe der bar tobias und michael
könnten zu fuß zur arbeit gehen also
park ist
also nicht die neueste aber schon über
leider nähe dafür platz für ein ja für
alle meine vorfindet kann ich hier
aufständen heimat ist für mich
dass ich das liegt das sieht schon dass
ich jetzt cool und wir werden dann die
wohnung nehmen dann sicherlich muss
alles dann noch mal schnell neue putzen
nicht ins wasser also ja also kannst du
planst
tobias und michael sind angetan der
haken bei der besichtigten wohnung
handelt es sich um ein muster
appartement
das eigentliche appartement ist momentan
noch bewohnt und liegt nicht in diesem
teil der anlage
sagt doreen schauen wir einfach umhaut
um die ecke im moment sind xxl pflanzen
oder 80 wohnungen würden schon besser
aussehen als hier jetzt draußen aber
voll komischer zeit aber es kommt eine
jährliche bisschen makaber ist der
garten gebracht
[Musik]
das support dieses risiko alle
partnerkarten nicht
aus ich denke ich habe genug gesehen
[Musik]
auf der insel bali renoviert romano zu
die seit sieben wochen das gästehaus
allein ohne seine frau patricia die
kommt aber bald nach romano gibt dem
umbau den letzten schliff
[Musik]
glaubt hoffentlich sehr
wohl einen fehler und es erwartet
die heimlich
drei gästezimmer wollen sie vermieten
romano ließ die räume neu streichen
betten nachttische und kommoden hatte
von einem schreiner anfertigen lassen
nach seinen wünschen auf bali ist das
nicht viel teurer als wenn man die möbel
fertig kauft
[Musik]
die fassade war von termiten zerfressen
mittlerweile ist die repariert
viel arbeit und viel geld hat romano in
das projekt gesteckt
sie bereit sie ist schon speziell jetzt
offiziell schock war alt und
jetzt in den schoß anderer fotos
ideen.de freue mich so
[Musik]
frau kampusch mit
in der schweiz deckt sich ehefrau
patricia mit pinseln und anderen
utensilien ein bilder malen ist ihr
liebgewonnenes hobby das sie auch auf
bali weiterführen möchte
raus aus dem grauen alltag das ist der
plan von moody's für patricia heißt dass
sicherheiten aufgeben
und doch
ruhig die miteinander setzen und die
dann könnte es sein traum so lang es der
mensch ist einfach einmal machen und
einmal probieren wie so ein spiel
zeitraum
[Musik]
clearwater liegt am rande der rocky
mountains
4000 einwohner leben hier weit verstreut
zwischen den bergen
die auswanderer sind endlich am ziel
gerade noch rechtzeitig zur übernahme
ihres neuen heims
das haus haben die volks noch von der
schweiz aus gekauft zusammen mit einem
stück wald das so groß ist die 90
fußballfeldern
vorbesitzerin christi erwartet sie
bereits
das haus ist teilweise eingerichtet
volks haben einige möbel von der
vorbesitzerin übernommen
[Musik]
das neue heim ist 450 quadratmeter groß
und hat sechs zimmer
[Musik]
ich das richtig will ich immer noch dass
mirko in dem haus schlecht und wir nicht
[Gelächter]
richtig steil
knapp 500000 franken hat familie volk
für das haus bezahlt
im verkaufspreis ist auch schon die
outdoor ausrichtungen teilten ein quad
und ein motorboot
[Musik]
sie lassen das alles hier vielen dank
setz dich mal auf den chefstuhl
alles da für einen kanadischen lifestyle
familie volk im glück
[Musik]
auf fuerteventura finden tobias bayer
und michael paris einfach keine gute
alternative zu ihrem teuren
ferienappartement
deshalb haben sie weitere immobilien
makler kontaktiert
ich hoffe einfach oder danken wir dir
noch eine gant mit seiner baath-partei
und hoffen dass man irgendwie es
erfahrungsberichte
auch mit ihrer bar dem stars ford event
uhr geht es nur schleppend voran der
ausbau ist schon wochen in verzug
im einkaufszentrum l campana rio liegt
das zukünftige lokal bereits vor zwei
monaten hatten die beiden eine
architektin beauftragt mit dem ausbau zu
beginnen
nun haben sie zwar die fertigen pläne
und offerten aber gebaut wurde er immer
noch nichts die architektin hat ihnen
jetzt zum dritten mal versichert dass es
endlich losgeht erschienen das eine sei
lacht erwartet
das gefühl dass sorgen level körperbau
arbeit
weiterhin ausbauen
aber da hat das irgendwie muss ja auch
unter die hand gab es ist schade
dass er
wenn du nicht da bist dann funktion
einfach nichts
[Musik]
je schneller augen dass man so gut sehen
das logo anbringen und präsenz markieren
mehr können die auswanderer momentan
nicht tun
hallo schrank
ist ein schrank gut in kanada versucht
sich familie volk im neuen leben
einzurichten
[Musik]
die volks haben zwar einige möbel
übernommen aber ihr eigene hausrat fehlt
noch der container aus der schweiz kommt
erst in ein paar wochen
sind drei
bisher machen bereits beim markt am aus
der luftmatratze auf
die schweizer improvisieren familie volk
teilt sich zu dritt ein bett mir konnte
kommt die luftmatratze
lässt sich schon selbst jetzt man doch
nicht statt für deutsche staat bald auf
ein abstecher ins dorf ist ganz im sinn
der beiden männer
hunger also weiß ich dass
ich das nicht machen
es ist
aber das erste bier trinken
ob sich die beiden an die abmachung
halten
ich weiß nicht ob ich dir
zusammenbringen bereich das nicht wenn
es einfach so ist das denkbar dass sarah
fertig bauen kann
weil ich okay
[Musik]
ein quatsch
aber
jetzt kann ich mal schießen wird es
nicht so lebenswichtig
simone ist zum ersten mal in ihrem
riesigen haus allein
nicht da mache ich mir das schönste das
mahnmal ende habe ich muss dazu muss der
käufer rosen oder nervt mich
die zwei männer durch deine blöde kassel
[Musik]
christian und marco haben tatsächlich
auf einen abstecher in eine bar
verzichtet und sind nach kurzer zeit
zurück
[Musik]
also kombi geht herr beer
auf kanada 5
[Musik]
der internationale flughafen in dem
passat
romano und patricia können sich endlich
wieder in die arme schließen nach sieben
wochen trennung
auf die sieger
ich auch nicht
für diesen besonderen moment hat romano
seinen balinesischen sachen angezogen
hier empfangen patricia tropische 30
grad nachdem sie die schweiz an einem
kalten winterabend verlassen hat
das taxi bringt dies nach oben
romano wohnt nach wie vor in einem
günstigen hotel an ortrand
[Musik]
gut gemacht
mehrere dieser see gelangt
bist du
jetzt wo patricia da ist wurden sich zu
dies eine dauerhafte bleibe suchen
ab morgen wird es ernst mit dem
gemeinsamen projekt
[Musik]
tobias und michael haben verschiedene
makler kontaktiert aber bisher keine
antwort bekommen und ihr budget schmilzt
mit jedem tag
wohnungen in corralejo zentral auf den
kanarischen inseln sind so viele
touristen wie lange nicht mehr die
urlauber meiden ägypten tunesien und die
türkei
bald haben tobias und michael alle
makler abgeklappert als auch nicht
ja
wir suchen eine wohnung
die ihr würden fast alles nehmen noch
eine einzimmerwohnung wir brauchen etwas
längerfristiges für sechs oder zwölf
monate
im moment ist alles voll
hoffentlich bis bald
das ist ja außer der sache pulsiert und
das gibt situation verteidiger
schließlich lernten sie wieder bei ihrer
ersten station makler jan-olaf sie
hoffen auf ein neues angebot
drückt sie sind nicht da wir haben
doch wie es der zufall will treffen die
auswanderer makler jan-olaf ein paar
minuten später auf der straße
sind sie gerade auf dem weg ins büro wir
wollten sie besuchen und fragen ob sie
vielleicht etwas hart
ich hätte womöglich eine wohnung mit
drei schlafzimmern wäre das was für sie
ist nicht sehr teuer
700 750 plus nebenkosten
mietbeginn wäre am ersten mai es ist
also noch etwas zeit aber
es wäre gut wenn wir die wohnung morgen
anschauen können ich melde mich wenn ich
alle details
vielen dank auch auf der straße kann man
geschäfte machen
ihre ausdauer könnte sich für die beiden
doch noch auszahlen
[Musik]
in kanada ist die erste nacht
überstanden christian hat sich einen
riesigen wohnwagen angeschafft er wird
für die nächste zeit das reich von
mitarbeiter merken
dass immer mit dem wasser sie stehen gar
kein desaster system vom ruß trier
christian möchte den wohnwagen fix neben
dem haus platzieren
das problem der schlauch fürs abwasser
[Musik]
mirko und christian sind über die jahre
zu freunden geworden er gehört schon
fast zur familie
[Musik]
baustelle nummer
der dumme
[Musik]
geschichte
ja
was tipptopp der abwasser schlauch ist
angeschlossen jetzt muss der wagen nur
noch gerade gestellt werden
wir
uns
und für mich allein ist dafür im moment
mirko kann sich schon wohnlich
einrichten familie volk hingegen wartet
weiter auf den container mit den möbeln
[Musik]
32 grad palmen und ein sandstrand so
weit das auge reicht alltag auf bali
ja
huber
[Musik]
das neue leben der tu dies könnte
perfekt sein
doch patricia hat keine ruhe sie will
jetzt das gästehaus sehen
in gut einem touristenort im
landesinneren wollen sie sich mit ihren
drei gästezimmern eine neue existenz
aufbauen
das haus liegt in einem vorort von ubud
mit dem motorroller zehn minuten vom
zentrum entfernt
städten stellen downfall kokosnuss
stelle wurde abgeholt wird
also etwas mehr als der schütze
aufgefallen ist es ist
schön bist du bist meine tritt usa
untersagt was tust du es weißt
doch was tut sich eine zusätzlich holten
auch beim flog auf ja aber wenn sie es
kurs
kurator jörg schmidt mit einem motor
scooter für mir der marke stihl
ersten
45 minuten
das braucht
[Musik]
und
als die studie geschnitten das ding hat
der sonst auch gedruckt des actions
das ist das
zdf
mit der schlange sondern hier schlagen
das kann nicht lange in romano scheint
leiser ärger aufzusteigen nun zeigt der
patrizia die zimmer die er mit viel
herzblut renoviert hat
überhaupt
doch die schlanke weiß
ja
ja ja
nicht ich schätze mal fertig sind ja das
sagt timo
stehn wird staub damit so holczer und
wenn zum buchhalter von
ökostrom wenn du denn die erste cache
dann soll es ja einigermaßen 20 ja hallo
südliche holt wer sagt dir einfach wenn
du zehn erst im juni und juli bestätigte
porsche wird gesprochen genau das hatte
man ins lager sollen nein so schön ist
unklar doch recht
[Musik]
den gemeinsamen start hat sich romano
wohl anders vorgestellt
[Musik]
handschuhe und gebügeltes hemd auf
fuerteventura haben sich tobias und
michael in schale geworfen makler jan
olov hat eine wohnungsbesichtigung
organisiert
vorher noch ein abstecher in die bar
und siehe da
[Gelächter]
der elektriker fängt wohl an die
leitungen zu legen
aber es war gestern noch nicht da aber
selbst ein von ihm bestellter
sofort mit gas heizt damit verschaffe
und kann man mit gelogen die zweite
problem große problem wohnungen
im zentrum von corralejo sind sie mit
makler jan olov verabredet
er bringt den schlüssel
sie sind gut organisiert
die wohnung befindet sich im zweiten
stock eines mehrfamilienhauses
die auswanderer könnten sie für ein jahr
mieten
sie hat vier zimmer und gehört einer
familie aus indien
[Musik]
die gehobene ausstattung hat ihren preis
750 euro plus nebenkosten verlangt der
besitzer pro monat
michael schaudt vor allem nach der
sauberkeit
für den ersten blick ja
kann man nicht vergleichen gewann der
hengst vater ja jetzt
schon nicht mehr ins spiel
aber ja als notlösung ja wir kommen also
nur zum schlafen hier so wir sind ganz
darum arbeiten immer schnell nicht
also würde schon eher in frage kommen
gegenüber der andere wohnung wir müssen
darüber nachdenken und bilden uns
wir würden die wohnung nicht an jeden
vermieten sie muss in
gute hände ja in gute hände diesen op
aus oder die leute sehen manchmal anders
aus als sie sind
sie haben trägt
danke für ihre zeit
ich könnte mit dem besitzer sprechen
vielleicht macht er einen besseren preis
wenn wir die wohnung für 650 euro haben
könnten plus nebenkosten dann würden wir
sie ziemlich sicher nehmen wie viel
meinen sie 100 weniger 650 euro
ich denke nicht aber ich werde mein
bestes versuchen
ich spreche mit ihm
wenn der besitzer darauf eingeht sind
wir dabei
ich melde mich später ich habe ja eben
tobias und michael programm wenn ihnen
der indische besitzer entgegenkommt
stimmt es für ihr knappes budget
[Musik]
auf bali beginnt der zweite tag im neuen
leben von patricia
die sicherheit aus dem schweizer alltag
ist weit weg
mit den bad oberdorf in dem rasen ja
christian geduld zahlte
[Musik]
ihr durch das
miese ob sie wirklich vertrauen
kurz und knackig schon nach drei wochen
das ist nicht ganz richtig
manchmal gut wenn dich lieb
ob sie dort überhaupt mal
gewitzt benito jetzt gesehen im prinzip
was man alles nur mitmachen und
einem das machte bez ernährung
sei dank ist sie
okay
[Musik]
danke das macht für sie habe wir haben
1000 das budget und durch und nimmt mir
dazu
da druck ins tor aber wenn ich mir jetzt
vor dem druck wird
ein
verstoss
kühl und hornau djk ich hoffe und
geschätztes nicht ja
jo
b
[Musik]
bei familie volk heißt es ab in ihrem
wald
65 hektar gehören ihnen ein schatz für
christian
auch schon vor 80 jahren suchten siedler
sogenannte home städter hier ihr glück
unterstellen tweets glaube der größte
traum sicher fühlen so einen riesen
stück land kaufen
und gerade als hat so
erklang kaufpreises gehört dauern also
ich habe darauf machen war nicht gerade
irgendwo ein riesenschock und ich als
rote island machen ich konnte
nicht einfach machen warme rot
christian fühlt sich hier pudelwohl
der wald ist mittlerweile wieder recht
verwildert ein abenteuerspielplatz für
die ganze familie
weißt du
was
[Musik]
cool ist wie bereits ihre drei komme
und er gerade strabag war sowohl von der
homestake
war die wiese
das liegt
einfach zu sehr schnell einig sei
[Gelächter]
und schon sind christian und schon
wieder im wald
jetzt aber nu vergessen
und dann schießt sieben große b
irgendwo muss er ja sein der bär
[Musik]
ist druck da
ist es passiert bei
[Musik]
hänge wo es gebiete im abwasser in
keinem
stau
im heizungsraum so schieße
[Musik]
nächste woche land unter bei familie
frank
christian hat seinen ersten auftrag aber
der zoll lässt die holzernte maschine
nicht passieren franz-josef ohne dass
die raupen doch kontaminiert sind auf
bali kämpfen shootings um gäste
eine traditionelle opferzeremonie soll
die götter günstig stimmen
die bauarbeiten gehen auf fuerteventura
endlich voran aber nicht alles läuft
nach plan die halterung für die disco
ist nicht übermittelt und michaels
duftwasser sammlung
weg kommt endlich ein neues plätzchen
ich muss nicht die ganze welt
träumen
die
wiener spö ist offen sid
[Musik]